The little prince's
asteroid B612
is being orbited
by a small body.
It has a mass m.
And it goes around this asteroid
B612 that has a mass m1.
We should add a
coordinate system.
We always know about r-hat
goes radially outward.
And we know from the
universal law of gravitation
that we have mutual attraction
between these bodies.
And actually, that's
going to point inward.
And because we're having
orbital motion here,
so circular motion,
the acceleration,
the radial component
of the acceleration
will also point inward.
We need to consider all of that
for our f equals ma analysis
that we are going to do now,
because the little prince wants
to know how far this little
body is away from his asteroid.
So we have the gravitational
universal law here,
minus Gmm1 over the
distance squared.
So the distance here
between the two planets,
r, which is what we
want to calculate.
And then we have over
here for circular motion,
the description of
mr omega squared.
Now, the little prince
can't measure omega.
But the little prince
has a little time clock.
So what he can measure
is the period from here
until he sees the body again.
And that is 2pi over omega.
So we can add that in here.
mr 4pi squared over T squared.
And this m here will cancel out.
And we have to solve this for r.
What we're going to see--
Oh and of course,
we have a minus sign
here because in the life
of the little prince,
of course gravitational
acceleration
is not going outwards.
It's going inward, so we better
give this a minus here and here
as well.
And we will actually
see that that then
cancels out against this one.
And we're going to
solve this for r.
So we get r cubed, actually.
And then we have Gm1
over 4pi squared.
And here, we have T squared.
And you can also just write that
as Gm1 or pi squared T squared.
And then we have third root.
So you might have seen
this equation here.
This is actually Kepler's law.
It describes the motion of
the planets around the sun.
Well, it really only
does it if the motions
are fairly circular.
For elliptical orbits, it is
not such a good approximation,
although Kepler derived it
like that quite a while ago.
And that was really
an astonishing result.
So here, we have this
again that the cube
of the distance
between two objects
is proportional to the square
of the period of the orbiting
time.